>> Laura: TIME FOR OUR "SEEN
AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT.
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON BEHIND
THE BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF THE
DAY.
TOPICS RUN THE GAMUT FROM THE
MEDIA BLACKOUT ON TODAY'S
PRO-LIFE WALKOUT ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND THE MAYOR OF LONDON
CALLING FOR KNIFE CONTROL AFTER
HE SEES MURDER RATE IS
SURPASSING NEW YORK.
WE ARE JOINED BY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
RAYMOND, WHERE DO WE START?
>> WE HAVE TO START WITH SADIQ
KHAN, THE MAYOR OF LONDON, KNIFE
CONTROL.
THIS IS THE SAME MAN, TO REMIND
EVERYBODY COME IN TWO YEARS AGO,
HE RESCINDED THE POLICY OF
SEARCHING AND STOPPING PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT HAVE KNIVES, MIGHT
HAVE WEAPONS BECAUSE HE SAID
IT'S RACIST AND MIGHT BE
ISLAMAPHOBIC.
>> Laura: DO THEY ONLY STOP
ISLAMIC --
>> THEY STOPPED A LOT OF ISLAMIC
FOLKS BECAUSE THESE ARE MEMBERS
OF GANGS.
IT'S MOSTLY GANG ACTIVITY IN
LONDON.
EIGHT TO 15 KNIFE ATTACKS A DAY
IN LONDON.
NOW HE'S PASSING THESE KNIFE
CONTROL MEASURES WHICH MEANS YOU
CANNOT HAVE KNIVES DELIVERED TO
YOUR HOME AND YOU CAN'T ORDER
THEM ONLINE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT WEDDING
REGISTRIES?
STEAK KNIVES ARE GREAT.
THE GINSU KNIFE SET IS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE THINGS TO GET ON LATE
NIGHT TV.
>> YOU BETTER BORROW IT FROM
SOMEONE ELSE.
THIS IS WHAT HE TWEETED.
HE SAID "I AM JOINING -- OH,
SORRY.
>> Laura: NO EXCUSES.
EVERYONE WHO CARRIES THE KNIFE
WILL BE CAUGHT.
A KNIFE.
IF YOU ARE A TECH GUY, YOU WORK
ON -- YOU NEED A KNIFE.
>> Laura: WE USE KNIVES THAT
MY HOUSE TO JUST CUT STUFF.
>> A PSYCHOLOGIST QUOTED IN THE
LONDON TIMES, WHY DO WE NEED
THESE DEADLY WEAPONS AT HOME.
WE NEED CURVED INSTRUMENTS.
IT'S A COUNTRY OF BUTTER KNIVES
APPARENTLY.
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THEY GONNA
USE?
>> WHAT NEXT?
>> Laura: SEAN DUFFY IS A BIG
LUMBERJACK IN WISCONSIN.
HE WAS A LUMBERJACK.
IN THE OLD DAYS.
THIS IS COMICAL NOW.
THIS IS WHAT EVERYBODY USED TO
JOKE ABOUT.
WHAT'S NEXT?
HAIR SPRAY.
THAT COULD BE DEADLY.
>> PIANO WIRE.